DANGEROUS, VERY SAD DEVELOPED
TODAY.
WE WILL GO BACK TO DAN
THROUGHOUT THE EVENING.
DARRELL SCOTT SPOKE ON
CAPITOL HILL DURING A HEARING ON
POLICE PRACTICES, LET’S TAKE A
LOOK.
>> THE LAW-ABIDING MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY WILL BE DIRECTLY
THREATENED BY THE ABSENCE OF
POLICE OR THE INABILITY OF
POLICE TO RESPOND TO CRIMINAL
ACTIVITIES, AND IN MANY CASES
WOULD ENDEAVOR TO TAKE THE LAW
INTO THEIR OWN HANDS TO ENSURE
THEIR SAFETY AND WELL-BEING.
FICO REMOVING THESE SERIES EUROS
YOUR COMMUNITY AND MY COMMITTEE
WILL DO NOTHING.
THEY PUT THE EVILDOERS AMONG US
AND THE HARDEST HARDWORKING
AMERICANS.
>> JOINING US NOW FOR REACTION,
WE HAVE FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
DAN BONGINO.
CONGRESSMAN GATES IS WITH US.
YOU TALKED ABOUT AND I WATCHED
THE PASSION, THE HEROES.
AND THE ODDS WERE, THEY EVEN AND
LEFT MESSAGES FOR LOVED ONES.
DID WE FORGET THE 99?
LOOKS LIKE IT.
>> I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
WATCHING HAVEN’T, EITHER.
BUT SADLY, MANY HAVE.
NO OFFENSE TO THE PEOPLE IN THE
MEDIA BUSINESS.
YOU KNOW I LOVE YOU AND MATT AND
DARRELL BUT THE FINEST WOMEN
I’VE EVER MET IN MY LIFE WERE IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT, AND THE FACT
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN SO
CASUALLY -- >> Sean: I AGREE
WITH YOU.
SO MANY OF MY FAMILY AND
FRIENDS -- I AGREE WITH YOU.
>> THESE ARE THE FINEST WOMEN
I’VE EVER MET.
YOU KNOW, IT TURNS OUT THE
PRECINCT GUY USED TO WORK IN THE
7-5.
YOU KNOW HOW MANY OF THOSE GUYS
I WALKED BY?
I WAS A ROOKIE AND THEY PROBABLY
DIDN’T SAY MUCH TO ME BUT I
CASUALLY WALKED BY IN THE
PARKING LOT OF THE 7-5 THAT ARE
DEAD TO, NOT AROUND ANYMORE?
AND THAT’S NOT TO DISTRACT AT
ALL.
THAT’S A POLICE REFORM SITTING
DOWN WITH THE UNIONS, THAT’S ALL
WE TALK ABOUT WHEN WE ARE
TOGETHER.
A MARTIAL ARTS.
>> YEAH BUT THROWING THEM
OVERBOARD, THE COPS.
I FELT SOME OF THE DEMOCRATS,
NOT ALL, REALLY DID A DISSERVICE
YESTERDAY BY TURNING TO ATTACK
THE COPS.
IT REALLY WAS UNNECESSARY.
WE HAD A MOMENT OF BIPARTISAN
UNITY.
>> LET ME GO TO AND PASTOR
SCOTT.
WE HAVE A TALK OF ARMED
VOLUNTEERS, AND HE FELL TO GUARD
THEIR COP FREE ZONE AND TAKING
OVER THE PRECINCTS.
FOR 32 YEARS, THERE WAS A SHOW
ON TELEVISION I LIKE TO CALL THE
COPS.
THERE IS A SHOW ON THE WEEKEND
CALLED LIVES PD WITH DAN ABRAMS.
YOU KNOW I LIKE?
WE HAVE CAMERAS ON, AND I THINK
EVERY COP NEEDS A BODY CAM AND
EVERY CRUISER NEEDS A CAMERA.
LET’S KEEP EVERYBODY HONEST,
LET’S PROTECT CITIZENS AND
POLICE THAT THEY WERE GOOD,
HONEST JOB.
AND I LIKE THOSE SHOWS.
I LOOK AT WHAT WE HAVE TO DO
EVERY DAY ON THE GOOD PEOPLE
THAT DO RESPOND PROPERLY, AND
HOW DO YOU RESPOND PROPERLY.
AND THEY TAKE THE ABUSIVE
ELEMENT OUT OF POLICING >>
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
AS WE ARE SAYING TODAY, PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO TAKE THE LAW INTO
THEIR OWN HANDS WHEN IT COMES
TIME TO DEFEND THEMSELVES
BECAUSE OF THE STAND-DOWN ORDER
THAT SOME OF THESE DEMOCRATIC
POLITICIANS ARE ISSUING AGAINST
THE POLICE.
I’M GLAD OUR PRESIDENT IS A LAW
AND ORDER PRESIDENT AND EVERY
LAW-ABIDING CITIZEN IN THIS
COUNTRY STANDS BEHIND HIM AND
STATING, YOU KNOW, DAN BONGINO
SAID, IF YOU PUT A BAD APPLE,
ONE GOOD APPLE DOESN’T TURN THE
BAD APPLES GOOD TO COME BUT ONE
BAD APPLE CAN TURN THE GOOD
APPLES BAD.
WE DIDN’T THROW THE BABY OUT
WITH THE BATHWATER, THE POLICE
FORCES, I’M WATCHING THE
INTERACTIONS HERE, CANCELING
COPS AND LIFE PD, I THINK WE
NEED MORE CAMERAS.
CAMERAS SHOW US THE TRUTH.
>> IT DISARMS THE CITIES, AND I
THINK TODAY THE REPORTING YOU
JUST INDICATED SHOWS THAT ANTIFA
HAS NOT DESIGNATED SEATTLE.
AND ISOLATING AND REMOVING THE
BAD POLLUTANTS.